promise me that you understand that the  land grab of happiness  starts right now because happiness  drives everywhere I've met hundreds of  people that have left their jobs making  good money when they had college debt  eighteen percent compounded interest  because they need their mental health to  be happy and they were willing to take a  step back and in the seven year period  they won when you're 51 or when you're  91 they're gonna be stunned how little  you care how little it mattered and this  includes your parents and your siblings  there's unbelievable happiness that  comes along with self belief and and  recognizing how this plays out  please take a step back and think about  how awesome it actually is